[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
en association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec rue Martin directeur du
Leclerc de Bois-d'Arcy bonjour bonjour à
tous alors si vous êtes invité
aujourd'hui c'est pour parler ensemble
de la Grande Rencontre journée de
l'emploi organisée au magasin Leclerc de
Bois-d'Arcy ça se passe le 25 mars quels
sont les objectifs de cette journée bah
disons que les objectifs de cette
journée donc ce rendez-vous de l'emploi
il est fait pour de faire découvrir à
l'ensemble de la population et des gens
qui peuvent éventuellement être
intéressés le panel de d'emploi qu'on
peut qu'on peut leur proposer sur sur
les métiers de la grande distribution en
général et plus clairement sur le
magasin du Leclerc de Bois-d'Arcy Darcy
pardon sur un maximum de métiers
disponibles on embauche d'embauche en ce
moment et tout au cours de l'année c'est
donc un grand job dating qui se met en
place depuis quelques années les jobs
dating sont presque devenus monnaie
courante est-ce que c'est un
[Musique]
de recrutement d'avoir un job dating
comme ça une journée de Job Dating oui
tout à fait c'est un gain de temps pour
nous dans le sens où voilà vous allez
toucher un panel de de personnes qui
sont assez conséquent donc ça permet sur
une sur une une journée bien donnée de
voir un maximum un maximum de personnes
au lieu que ça soit dilué sur
xendez-vous entre tel et telle heure
tout le monde y trouve son compte au
sein du Leclerc de Bois d'Arcy 50 postes
sont à pourvoir cette année pour pour
cette deuxième édition de la Grande
Rencontre quels sont les postes à
pourvoir au moins quelques quelques
exemples sans citer les 50 oui tout à
fait on a plusieurs postes notamment des
postes en remplacement de congés on va
dire ce qu'on appelle un peu les jobs
les jobs étudiants d'été mais également
des jobs étudiants tout au cours de
l'année puisque en août et hôtesse de
caisse on recrute on recrute tout au
long de l'année on recrute jusqu'au
cuisinier pour nos notre cafétéria des
préparateurs de commande pour drive
éventuellement responsable qualité ça va
jusqu'au pharmacien des vendeurs ça soit
alimentaire ou non ou non alimentaires
bijoutier ou bijoutière caviste donc
vous voyez que le panel est assez large
et parmi les postes vous proposez donc
en CDI en CDD aussi en contrat
d'apprentissage en alternance ou en job
étudiant à vous l'avez vous l'avez
évoqué pourquoi ouvrir les possibilités
à tous ces publics disons que c'est
c'est nos métiers et c'est nos
collaborateurs nos futurs travailleurs
de demain
moi je prendrai toujours mon exemple
j'ai commencé dans grand distribution il
y a bientôt 30 ans c'était un contrat un
contrat étudiant je suis rentré sur pour
travailler sur le mois de juillet août
et j'ai envie de vous dire maintenant ça
fait 30 ans 30 ans que j'y suis avec
plusieurs plusieurs évolutions donc on
sait jamais on sait jamais lorsqu'on
ouvre une porte quand est-ce qu'elle va
se refermer sur quoi va se refermer donc
disons que on est on est aussi à des
croisements aussi des des chemins où il
y a beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui vont
partir en retraite donc on a besoin de
former de recruter tous les
collaborateurs tous les vendeurs tous
les tous les bijoutiers tous les métiers
de demain vous l'avez dit vous avez
vous-même commencé en tant que en tant
qu'emplois étudiant est-ce que c'est
justement votre votre passé finalement
votre début de carrière entre guillemets
qui a fait qu'aujourd'hui vous voulez
ouvrir l'accès à l'accès aux jeunes
l'accès à l'emploi pardon aux jeunes oui
toujours après faut savoir que nous
c'est pas une démarche qui est récente
on a toujours travaillé avec avec les
jeunes et que ça soit des des étudiants
ou des gens qui ont attendant de trouver
leur voie dans les études qu'ils ont pu
qu'ils ont pu avoir ben ça leur permet
d'avoir un travail d'être autonome pour
les étudiants de pouvoir faire leur
petit plaisir sortir le week-end
participer à au coût de leurs études et
pour les gens qui démarrent dans la vie
c'est toujours intéressant d'avoir un
premier un premier exemple un premier
pas dans dans le monde dans le monde du
travail dans le monde professionnel
aujourd'hui des l'association lutte pour
l'accessibilité à l'emploi des personnes
en situation de handicap ce public
est-ce que c'est également une cible
pour vous est-ce que les personnes en
situation de handicap peuvent postuler
oui tout à fait ils peuvent postuler
j'ai envie de dire ils peuvent postuler
toute l'année puisque ça fait partie
aussi de nos critères de de recrutement
il faut participer à participer à la vie
de la société et l'emploi l'emploi des
jeunes l'emploi des personnes dans une
situation situation de handicap ils ont
le droit au travail ils ont le droit
d'être indépendant ils ont le droit de
s'épanouir dans la vie sociale dans la
vie associative et dans la vie
professionnelle donc nous on n'a pas de
on n'a pas de critères d'embauche de ce
côté là les postes sont ouverts à tous
les personnes qui ont envie de
travailler est-ce que vous demandez des
compétences particulières ou des
diplômes particuliers pour pour cette
grande journée de rencontre non pas du
tout et ça c'est plutôt au cours de tout
au cours de l'année à part des métiers
bien spécifiques mais nous nous critères
principal de recrutement je viens de
c'est l'envie de travailler tout
simplement
on regarde pas au diplôme on regarde à
la personne à disponibilité l'envie
qu'elle a envie de travailler c'est
donner l'envie d'avoir envie donc c'est
c'est avoir tout simplement
besoin de travailler en vie de
travailler en équipe et de participer
voilà à au confort de nos de nos clients
la satisfaction de nos clients on va
parler un petit peu du programme de la
journée les jobs dating débute à 10h et
se termine à 17h dans la galerie
commerciale de votre centre Leclerc à
Bois-d'Arcy quel est le processus pour
se présenter à vous et que doit ramener
les candidats les candidats nous faut ça
le job dating sera comme l'année
dernière il se va se réaliser dans la
galerie commerciale du notre centre
Leclerc donc vous l'avez dit de 10
heures à 17h il y a un stand d'accueil
qui sera installé donc les candidats
muni d'un CV se présenteront au stand où
ils seront accueillis par une hôtesse ou
un auteur un autre à cet effet là qui
les aidons si nécessaire à finaliser la
recherche de poste
il y aura une fiche d'entretien à
remplir c'est dans un but de rencontrer
un recruteur et de passer un premier
entretien d'environ 10 minutes
par la suite il passe un entretien et se
voit le cas échéant recontacté pour par
recruteur pour un second entretien 10
minutes vous estimez que justement c'est
suffisant pour pour connaître un
candidat pour pour savoir si il est on
va dire assez compétent et surtout assez
motivé j'ai envie de dire que 10 minutes
ça peut paraître court et pour certains
ça peut paraître long en général on
échange assez rapidement et puis c'est
aussi une prise de contact une prise de
contact ça permet ça permet de de
d'avoir un lien directement avec avec le
candidat et pour les personnes qui n'ont
pas forcément le temps ou si on est
victime de notre succès comme ça peut ça
peut arriver tous les candidats ont la
possibilité
de déposer un CV et de demander un
entretien ils seront recontactés et vous
vous engagez à répondre dans les 10
jours il me semble pourquoi cette de cet
engagement bah nous en général les gens
qui postulent chez nous sont de toute
façon on s'engage à l'air à leur
répondre c'est toujours toujours un
minimum de politesse c'est vous êtes
sollicité le moins de la moindre des
choses c'est de leur répondre c'est ce
que ça soit négatif ou positif et je
tiens également à dire que en général
même si il peut y avoir des des profils
qui sont pas retenus à un moment T qu'on
a des profils qui nous semblent vraiment
intéressants souvent se permettent de
garder un garder un petit peu le CV ce
qu'on a quand même des turnover qui qui
sont qui sont plus ou moins importants
sur certains rayons au vu voilà vous
avez des étudiants si à un moment donné
leur cursus change ou leurs horaires
changent il y a des des contrats qui
peuvent qui peuvent changer donc on se
permet de garder garder les CV de
recontacter les personnes des fois il
peut y avoir une réponse négative et
éventuellement quelques mois ou quelques
semaines après on peut les appeler parce
que il y a un poste qui s'est libéré et
on a gardé ce
ce contact et vous proposer également
aux candidats de découvrir les coulisses
du magasin quels sont les objectifs de
cette découverte tout à fait bah les
objectifs de voir un petit peu les
coulisses du du magasin c'est de faire
connaître
à nos futurs collaborateurs ou aux
personnes qui ont qui ont envie de voir
un petit peu les l'arrière l'arrière du
théâtre parce que souvent les gens
viennent comme comme client donc ils
voient ils vont devoir qu'une partie du
du travail mais ils vont pouvoir
constater et souvent les gens sont
étonnés que on fabrique notre pain que
on fabrique notre pâtisserie que on a on
a des bouché qui découpe un découpe la
viande on a les poissonniers qui
préparent des plateaux de fruits de mer
qui prépare le poisson ça te permet à
chacun de voir le panel énorme de
travail et de possibilités qui peut qui
peut y avoir chez nous et même sans être
issus du métier et ça valorise en même
temps les métiers justement de de vos
employés merci beaucoup ruimartens
d'avoir été avec nous sur sensation donc
la grande journée de de rencontre de
l'emploi c'est le ce25 mars 2023 pour
plus d'informations on peut se rendre
sur le site recrutement point Leclerc et
pour revoir ou réécouter cette émission
rendez-vous sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation
[Musique]